[Music]
many recipes call for shredded
ingredients which is why a cheese grater
is an indispensable kitchen tool
depending on which type of blade or
blades a grater has you can coarsely
shred to finely grate not just cheese
but also potatoes and vegetables
[Music]
graters come in different sizes shapes
and configurations
from flat models with one blade
to box graters with a different blade on
each side
the blades are made from a stainless
steel sheet that's just 1 50th of an
inch thick
the sheet enters a shearing machine
where a dye descends and cuts the blade
shape holes and all
[Music]
the machine's dies are interchangeable
so when it's time to produce a different
model workers simply remove this die and
install another one
stainless steel is the ideal blade
material because it's food safe durable
and rust proof
for this model the next step is to curve
the blade
they insert it into a press that bends
it with a rounded die
the press also turns over the edges
along three sides forming a channel for
a handle
the handle is made of stainless steel
wire
[Music]
a bending machine wraps it around a
grader shaped form
then cuts the end free releasing what is
now a finished handle
[Music]
[Music]
now for this model's final assembly
workers slide a handle into the blade's
channels
[Music]
next they put the blade in a press which
forces the channels closed encasing the
wire
with the handle and blade now locked
together the grater is finished
[Music]
another model has a built-in tray to
collect the grated food
this machine forms the pivoting handle
which enables the blade to stand upright
in the tray
first the machine cuts a strip of
stainless steel to the required length
it makes holes for a rivet on each side
then it bends the piece to a u-shape
[Music]
meanwhile a forming press shapes the
tray out of a stainless steel sheet
[Music]
the tray moves to the next press which
slices off the excess from the perimeter
[Music]
[Music]
the tray is now completely formed
all that's left to do is punch a hole on
each side for the rivets that attach the
handle that props up the blade
they take the handle and rivet it to one
end of the blade
[Music]
next they rivet the tray to the other
end of the blade
and the grater is fully assembled
[Music]
this company packages certain models in
blister packs
workers put the grater in a clear
plastic cover
then position a printed cardboard
backing over it
the backing is coated with transparent
heat activated glue
a few seconds under a hot press
and the plastic cover adheres to the
backing encapsulating the grater
from a basic version on up a grader is
an essential kitchen tool most cooks
can't do without
[Music]
you